auf einer kufe anlage in helsinki
treffen sich die reservisten vom band an
club zum wöchentlichen training
will vorbereitet sein
ich hatte das gefühl
dass sich etwas tun muss ich kann das
land nicht einfach im stich lassen wenn
wir angegriffen werden
lilly hat vor 20 jahren ihren armee
dienst absolviert nach russlands
annexion der krim hat sie angefangen
regelmäßig kurse zu besuchen im winter
in der halle und größere übungen in den
wäldern im sommer
unsere militärs haben schon lange gesagt
die drei größten bedrohungen für
finnland sind russland russland und
russland
allein ellis verband hat seit
kriegsbeginn
360 neue mitglieder die kurse sind für
den rest des jahres ausgebucht
280.000 reservisten könnte finnland im
ernstfall mobilisieren für den
verbandsvorsitzenden ist der umgang mit
der waffe genauso wichtig wie schwimmen
und der nato beitritt die einzige
möglichkeit
entweder hast du die nato auf deiner
seite oder nicht wir können es uns nicht
mehr leisten nicht dabei
der beste zeitpunkt für den beitritt ist
jetzt der zweitbeste ist heute
vergangene woche haben finnland soldaten
im westen des landes mit truppen aus
großbritannien usa lettland und estland
ein manöver absolviert ein klares signal
für finnlands nato ambitionen und
rückendeckung für die finnische führung
die sicherheitsgarantien braucht
neutralität war seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg staatsraison in finnland jetzt
droht russland mit harten konsequenzen
sollte der nato-beitritt folgen der
außenminister reist viel in diesen tagen
wir treffen pkh visto kurz zwischen
seinen besuchen in den hauptstädten der
andere nato länder
wie sicher sind sie dass finnland
nato-mitglied wird
nun ja ich denke es ist sehr
wahrscheinlich wir haben unsere
nationalen schritte da debattiert das
parlament zur zeit und eine breite
mehrheit der abgeordneten ist dafür und
dann kommt noch der andere teil die 30
nato mitglieder müssen neuen kandidaten
zu stimmen das sind die signale die wir
bekommen sehr unterstützen
wie sehen sie denn diese historische
abkehr von der neutralität
wir sehen entscheidende veränderungen
für europa sicherheit zunächst haben die
europäischen sicherheitsstrukturen
versagt den krieg zwischen russland und
der ukraine zu verhindern
beziehungsweise den russischen angriff
auf die ukraine
zweitens sehen wir wie die
unvorhersehbaren elemente stärker werden
und zum schluss wird offener über
atomwaffen und auch chemiewaffen
gesprochen
das sind bedrohungen gegen die wir uns
mit unserem eigenen militär nicht
schützen kann
ich erlebe einem politiker der die
vorteile eines nato beitritts sehr
pragmatisch sieht und der dann zum ende
des interviews doch noch einmal die
heikle übergangsphase bis zur
vollmitgliedschaft anspricht
machen sie sich denn sorgen was diese
phase wenn sich eine organisation bei
ihrer entscheidung von einer drittpartei
hineinreden lassen würde und wenn sie
einen kandidaten deshalb die
beitrittsperspektive verweigert dann
wäre das keine politik der offenen tür
mehr es ist im eigeninteresse der nato
dieses prinzip zu schützen
jahrzehnte war der nato-beitritt kein
großes thema in helsinki bloß keine
schlafenden bären wecken gute
beziehungen zum nachbarn waren wichtiger
von einem tag auf den anderen hat sich
die stimmung gedreht eine klare mehrheit
unterstützt jetzt den nato beitritt
ich war lange gegen die nato beitritt
aber jetzt glaube ich auch wenn wir nur
auf schlechten optionen auswählen können
dass die nato die weniger schreckliche
und die einzige mögliche option ist
ich habe mich noch nicht entschieden ich
verstehe waren die leute für den
beitritt sind
aber ich finde dass wir insgesamt noch
nicht genug in den medien und auf
regierungsebene darüber gesprochen haben
was die negativen seiten sind
[Musik]
die friedensaktivisten aber und valtteri
gehören mit ihrer kritik am nato
beitritt zu den wenigen ausnahmen die
sich öffentlich äußern nach
fernsehauftritten haben sie in den
letzten tagen wütende mails und anrufe
bekommen
weil wir gegen den nato beitrage ich
finde das nicht fair die alternative ist
ja nicht ein putin ist zu sein sondern
einfach nicht der nato beizutreten
zb wären nato militärbasen in finnland
meiner meinung nach eine große bedrohung
die von den vorteilen einer
mitgliedschaft nicht aufgewogen werden
fürchten sie sollte finnland der nato
beitreten
wenn russland uns angreifen sollte dann
würde das zu einer direkten
konfrontation zwischen 20 klar mächten
führen russland und den usa als teil der
nato das ist meine größte angst
ich glaube es ist ein ganz natürlicher
wunsch aber die falsche antwort wenn es
um militärbündnisse geht sollten die
entscheidungen weil sie finden dann sehr
lange betreffen werden auch sehr
gründlich durchdacht werden und nicht
als reaktion auf ein ereignis erfolgen
trotz ihrer neutralität haben sich die
finnen immer auf einen möglichen angriff
vorbereitet dieses schwimmbad ist
gleichzeitig einer der größten
schutzräume der stadt
wir sind mit elektronen verabredet damit
er uns erklären kann was im notfall
passiert
kaum zu glauben dass das hier ein bunker
sein soll
war das vorher ein bunker oder ein
schwimmbad das zu einem bunker wurde es
wurde als bunker und als schwimmbad
gebaut
also beides genau helsinki hat viele
solcher anlagen die im alltag als
sportstätten genutzt werden jeder
bewohner hat einen fest zugewiesenen
platz im ernstfall haben die mitarbeiter
72 stunden zeit um das bad in einem
bunker zu verwandeln
wir lassen all das wasser raus
und natürlich schließen wir die türen
wir haben dann platz hierfür 3800
menschen
drei wochen lang können wir hier unten
nur mit wasser überleben auch wenn es
nicht besonders komfortabel
wie fühlt sich das an dass das bad ein
puffer werden könnte
ich bin einfach froh dass wir diese orte
haben
in den ukrainischen städten mussten die
menschen unter ihren häusern in ziemlich
kalten bunkern ausharren das ist
ungemein
dann führt uli kunz noch ein stockwerk
tiefer
seit 30 jahren hat hier niemand mehr
geprobt wie alles funktioniert aber seit
dem krieg in der ukraine überprüft der
katastrophenschutz alle anlagen in der
stadt
zeigt uns die stahltüren mit denen der
jetzige lieferanteneingang im falle
eines angriffs versiegelt werden kann
hier haben wir zwei türen die erste ist
für den druck diese schützt vor gas
türen dior lag bisher noch nie schließen
musste
finnland hat eine lange wechselhafte
beziehung mit russland und bis heute
eine große russe sprachige minderheit
mit der finnisch russischen gesellschaft
hat nina zinco über jahre versucht
brücken zu bauen den austausch mit
museen theatern und partnerstädten zu
vertiefen seit dem krieg hat sie alle
projekte gestoppt wer alle ich auch sind
viel kritischer geworden warum wir so
viel toleriert haben
ohne einen politischen neuanfang in
russland sieht nina keine zusammenarbeit
mehr heute hilft sie denen den helsinki
versuchen ein neues leben aufzubauen
in diesen räumen wurde viel tee
getrunken in den letzten wochen
viele von ihnen saßen auf genau diesen
stühlen und sofas
sie kommen nach finnland und haben oft
überhaupt keine zukunft wir geben ihnen
telefonnummern von entscheidungsträgern
von denen die sich um ihre papiere
kümmern wir versuchen ihnen zu helfen
nina begleitet uns in die wohnung eines
russen der gerade vor der eigenen
regierung nach helsinki geflogen ist die
meisten wollen nicht offen sprechen oft
um freunde und familie nicht in gefahr
zu bringen
babbels schenke nimmt kein blatt vor dem
mund der theatermacher und maler zeigt
mir die wohnung die er über freunde
gefunden hat
ist es schwierig hier zu arbeiten nein
für mich ist es als würde ich eine neue
seite in meinem leben aufschlagen
vor einem monat ist babbel mit seiner
frau aus sankt petersburg gekommen nach
jahren in denen er offen kritik äußern
konnte musste er jetzt die arbeit in
seinem atelier aufgeben seine russischen
mitbürger plötzlich sind sie feinde für
ihn
das ist faschismus
unsere regierung tötet zivilisten
viele die sich ja keine faschings
sie übertönen das mit propaganda
und viele russen sind wirklich wie
zombies
und wie fühlt es sich jetzt an in finden
als russe
[Musik]
als sich die grenze überwunden habe
konnte ich zum ersten mal wieder frei
atmen
das ist nicht physisch es ist im kopf
und im herz
meine hände haben gezittert
von der wachsenden spannung ist in
helsinki auf den ersten blick nicht viel
zu sehen die finnen sind von der eigenen
stärke überzeugt oder hoffen sich
mehrheitlich von der nato zusätzliche
sicherheit
am tag des sieges über nazi-deutschland
dann diese bilder ein autokorso mit
russischen und finnischen fahnen fährt
durch die ansonsten so ruhige hauptstadt
eine provokation für viele finnen ich
sehe am straßenrand immer wieder
proteste dagegen dass mitten in finnland
die propaganda des kreml verbreitet wird
es musste etwas getan werden
glaube sie den krieg ist etwas gutes es
gibt soviel faschismus und nazismus in
der ukraine und nicht nur in der
bevölkerung sondern auch bei denen an
der macht sind sie aus finnland ich
komme aus finnland aber ich bin russen
ich bin in russland geboren
auf der fähre zur alten festungs insel
sind wir noch einmal mit nelly der
reservisten verabredet ein symbol der
finnischen wehrhaftigkeit und ein
passendes motiv für die hobby fotograf
in finnland hat viele kriege geführt
gegen feinde aus dem westen und aus dem
osten sind stolz auf die eigene
unabhängigkeit doch lange hat sich keine
bedrohung so real angefühlt ja war in
den 90er jahren hatten wir schon einmal
diskussionen über den nato beitritt
damals sind estland lettland und weitere
länder in das militärbündnis eingetreten
wir haben uns damals entschieden diesen
weg nicht mitzugehen und ich denke dass
sich die geschichte wiederholen könnte
dass wir uns wieder gegen die nato
entscheiden und sich wieder nichts
verändert
russlands angriffskrieg hat definitiv
verunsichert die angst vor dem großen
nachbarn könnte finnland im eiltempo in
die nato treiben das ende der
neutralität
noch nie war es den finnen so wichtig
klar position zu beziehen